Donald Trump appears to have turned off
FoxNews literally and also turned on
FoxNews figuratively turned against them
so to speak at least weekend Fox News
and he is unleashed exactly the type of
unhinged Twitter storm that we've become
pretty used to actually as something
that the president does over the last
couple of years remember I told you
before there's nothing immutable or set
in stone about Fox News and Donald Trump
being aligned yes right now Trump mostly
as watching Fox News Trump mostly says
that Fox News is doing the right type of
reporting a Fox give Trump a lot of
ideas that then Trump sees on Fox and
Friends in the morning and then tweets
about all day or talks about for a few
days on the other hand yes mostly Fox
News supports Donald Trump sometimes
Shepard Smith or Chris Wallace will say
some basic uncontroversial truth a you
know fundamental real-world critique of
Donald Trump and the Fox News audience
will be angry with them even though in
most of the world what Fox and what Shep
and Chris Wallace say is just the truth
but remember that early in the 2016
Republican primary Fox News and Donald
Trump were not actually aligned and they
only later sort of joined forces
anyway Trump is furious check out this
series of tweets and as usual
imagine Barack Obama sitting around
tweeting stuff like this it's hard to
imagine because it would never have
happened because this is unlike anything
we've ever seen before in the Oval
Office Trump tweeting quote watching Fox
News weekend anchors is worse than
watching low ratings fake news CNN or
lyin Brian Williams remember when he
totally fabricated a war story trying to
make himself into a hero and got fired a
very dishonest journalist and the crew
of degenerate Comcast NBC MSNBC Trump
haters who do whatever Brian and Steve
tell them to do like CNN NBC is also way
down in the ratings but Fox News who
failed in getting the very boring dem
debates is now loading up with Democrats
and even using fake unsourced New York
Times as a source of information ask The
Times what they paid for the Boston
Globe and what they sold it for
1.5 billion dollars or their old
headquarters building disaster or their
unfunded liability Fox News is changing
fast but they forgot the people who got
them there this thing about they forgot
the people who got them there Trump
seems to have the relationship backwards
they got Trump there by jumping on his
side about halfway through the 2016
campaign when they saw that he actually
seemed to be appealing to a shockingly
high portion of the Republican
electorate and they kind of work
together and getting Trump to where he
is today now all of this happened why
it's not really clear we don't know it
appears that it might be because Fox
News broadcast the following video of
people in France watching the Women's
World Cup final and when Fox News goes
live the crowd knows it's Fox News and
they start chanting F Trump take a look
at this video just the funniest part
about this is that if this really is why
Trump lost it on Fox News it's not
really Fox's fault I mean Fox is doing
live TV this is what people started
chanting presumably unbeknownst to the
anchor as he went live but if this makes
Trump angry with Fox great because any
disruption to Fox being a total arm of
the Trump administration status quo is
great and from continuing his bizarre
attack on Fox later on saying quote
impossible to believe that Fox News has
hired Donna Brazile the person fired by
CNN after they tried to hide the bad
facts and failed forgiving her cat
Hillary Clinton the questions to a
debate something unimaginable now she is
all over Fox including Shep Smith by far
their lowest rated show watched the Fox
News weekend daytime anchors who were
terrible go after her big time that's
what they want but it sure is not what
the audience wants I don't really know
that a super deep analysis is even
required here I mean Trump is triggered
because he expects Fox News to be proach
from Beco chambers 24/7 occasionally
sometimes even by accident
the case of that video from the World
Cup of Paris F Trump chant something
will occasionally pierce the echo
chamber and Donald Trump gets mad this
guy is a very sensitive snowflake he
constantly attacks others as weak
soldiers who have PTSD are not strong
enough even though trump's dad paid a
doctor to write a letter about how
trump's ankles preclude him from going
to Vietnam
totally emasculated is Trump by the mere
mention of John McCain so he makes it
his job to attack McCain endlessly and
the most important implication is that
if the relationship between Trump and
Fox News breaks as the twenty20 election
gets closer that's a really good
opportunity for something other than Fox
News to be preventing to get into the
action and maybe we can get Trump
removed from office in the sense that
anything that disrupts this kind of hand
in glove relationship between Trump and
Fox News is great and we should make
sure to publicize anytime that there is
this apparent rift when Fox News
criticizes Trump it should be widely
publicized we know Trump will hear about
it we know it will trigger him we know
it will send him into another Twitter
frenzy and anything we can do to sever
that relationship is potentially going
to pay dividends in the 2020 election
now just as a word of warning
remember if Trump moves on from Fox as
his favorite he is probably going to
move on to promoting an even crazier
channel called it I don't remember if
it's Oh a N or oann I think it's like
one American news or the one American
news network I forget exactly it's even
more off the deep end than Fox News if
you can imagine it and check it out
online if you want although you may not
be thrilled about giving them any of
your web traffic and potentially ad
revenue but if Trump does sever the tie
with Fox he's probably going to oen and
they're even wackier and Oh a n rising
in terms of prominence in the United
States would be materially destructive
to everything we hold near and dear in
terms of the fabric of this country so
there's ups and downs I don't know what
do you think is going on with the Trump
Fox relationship let me know